so you want to harness the power of
machine learning for your business well
one of the first problems you'll need to
solve is what data you'll be using to
teacher models so you guys have like a
mantra right yes no data no mo what does
that mean exactly well your model is
only as good as the data it trains on
[Music]
luckily our professional services ml
team has refined a set of best practices
for selecting and preparing top-quality
data and we're itching to hand the goods
over is this the part where we tell them
all of our secrets that comes up in a
little bit later
first we'll reveal what goes into
choosing a highly effective data source
and later learn how to spot the most
common oversights our professional
services ml team helps correct for
clients so ready to become an
independent authority on good data let's
dive in rule number one clear labels
many companies use machine learning
because they want to predict some
outcome from detecting credit-card fraud
to forecasting ice cream sales from
recommendation systems to self-driving
cars whatever it is you're trying to
predict you'll need to feed the machine
some examples with known outcomes we
call those labels if you were teaching a
machine how to predict credit-card fraud
for instance you would tell the machine
for each new piece of data whether or
not fraud occurred this is what we mean
by known outcomes it may seem like a
small point but for businesses looking
to take advantage of ml to make accurate
predictions these labeled examples are
what allow algorithms to learn in the
first place I would say this is probably
the number one piece of advice we give
to our clients labels labels labels
labels is there anything else well
although more data is generally better
it has to be the right kind of data that
sounds pretty important maybe like rule
number two important rule number two
although more data is generally better
it has to be the right kind of data
continuing with our example if you want
your algorithm to predict credit card
fraud imagine all the information a
human being might rely on to do the same
task data like the amount
the transaction and where it took place
are definitely useful but cardholder
name that may not be as helpful here if
you're not sure erring on the side of
more data is always wise in the world of
machine learning we don't always know
with 100% certainty what's gonna be
relevant ahead of time expect to refine
as you go
sometimes relevant also means granular
suppose you wanted to predict whether on
an hourly basis but your data is only
collected daily let's say 3 p.m. your
model will learn how to predict the
weather sure but except for those of us
who decide what to wear based on the
temperature outside at exactly 3 p.m.
the model won't be as helpful as it
could be
this also means collecting data long
enough so if the target you're trying to
predict is periodic like ice cream sales
you'll need enough cycles for your model
to discover the general trend a good
rule of thumb is at least three this
table includes plenty of helpful columns
but which one that ml models depend on
to make accurate predictions is still
missing
you guessed labels right just checking
rule number three beware of biased data
granularity matters but some errors only
become obvious when we take a big step
backwards it's just like how we can tell
what a picture frame is leaning to one
side when we're standing far enough away
here will define bias as anytime your
training data skews towards some groups
more than the rest let's say you're
trying to predict customer satisfaction
well we know that online reviews tend to
over represent the most extreme views so
if you choose to train a model on these
reviews alone your model could become
biased now don't be alarmed if you have
a missing values in a large data set but
you should check to see whether these
missing values frequently leave out the
same group you might think that simply
collecting more data will solve the
problem but that's not always possible
and even if it were that's only a part
of the solution just as important if you
have a way to tell what dynamics are
causing the bias you may still be able
to quantify the effect and correct it by
for example adjusting the weighing and
different samples accordingly
expect to do some Corrections of your
data set and don't let perfect be the
enemy of great congratulations you're
more than halfway to maximizing the
power of your training data now let's
finish strong with some data preparation
rule number four use consistent terms
you'll want to make sure you're using
the same units across your data set
check not only for a quantitative units
like price but for categorical units as
well
this also means making sure the meaning
of the data in a given column is
consistent if a single price column
switches between wholesale and retail
price and you're missing a column that
identifies which is which your model
will treat these numbers as though they
measure the same thing even though they
don't rule number five out think data
leakage data leakage happens when you
train your model on information that
won't be available when it's time for
your model to actually do its job so
here's my favorite example let's say
you're teaching a model to pick out
which acoustic recordings contain calls
from an endangered species of whale what
if the recordings with the right audio
happened to be the same file size but
only do dozen processing that was done
on them your model could learn to rely
on file size instead of sound and later
when it's time to start making
predictions label all kinds of sounds as
well almost done let's quickly review
the basic principles labels labels
labels more data is good but it has to
be the right kind
beware of biased data use consistent
terms throughout your spreadsheets and
rule out data leakage and voila you're
ready to select the right data and make
sure it's looking good for your machine
learning algorithm for a more detailed
explanation check out the full article
on the Google cloud platform blog and
find a link to our ML data prep
checklist at the bottom have a tip you'd
like to share with us join the
conversation on our Twitter handle using
hashtag ml data prep and as always
thanks for watching
[Music]
[Music]